this place his favorite DTX E4 Bishop B4
check A5 he really loves this he
believes in it
then he wants to liquidate yeah he very
much believes I think this is also some
kind of a very old line which you
probably know from World Championship
matches probably 2010 Sophie I am yeah
but also later we started uh kind of
checking it of course because Magnus
started playing it a lot
um also here black uh black has even a
choice yeah black can take Bishop D2 and
can't even play Bishop E7 as far as I
remember uh yeah this is some new twist
yeah exactly people are playing this
bishop E7 move
yeah it's a yeah
yeah giving this option for Queen A4
check and then you go some Knight B7 C6
or something yeah yeah yeah but but this
is the old classical one yeah it takes
takes B5 B3 is uh
yeah as you say it's sort of classical
and then
um white usually gets a very pleasant
position with black has a pawn up
so um everybody's happy
yeah everybody's yeah I think you were
also playing this from the black side
well I had this one uh one game that uh
probably caught your attention yeah
yes I think so yes yes yes it was
against
yeah Queen takes B3 and then okay all
these kind of things yeah that it's uh
very ugly for black but at the same time
you are pulling up there is no clear
plan for I mean clear way for white to
to claim advantage and then white starts
to slowly shuffling the pieces look fc1
Queen B2 Knight B3 Knight E1 Knight D3 I
mean all all this kind of maneuvering
stuff starts that's very interesting
because it would create some additional
spice to I mean we would see first of
all game four but also Arjun would get
them the strengths maybe yeah
how did this happen yeah so Magnus
actually broke out with Knight E1 E5
yeah it's kind of a typical idea but
Arjun was not impressed he forced the
queen all the way to H6 but if you have
to go Queen H6 then maybe it's not a
great idea right it's just exactly and
and immediately start harassing this
bishop rugby at night DC
and B for your Magnus is trying to leak
with it but Arjun is not interested
Knight C5 Bishop A8 Queen takes A5
well this is serious trouble with this
terrible Bishop on A8 material I guess
yeah Bishop B7 he's not okay he's H6
he's he's just not even trying to get it
out right wow E4 immediately
yeah I would probably just go Queen A7
to prevent Bishop B7 I would not go E4
yeah E4 is little bit committed yeah
that's you we don't want to weaken the
squares
I find in general that if you don't play
E4 or move one then you might as well
you know leave it yeah it goes for
Knight DC he wants to yeah but but I'm
not liking this the Knight was so
powerful on C5 okay Magnus goes Queen E6
now Queen e6e5 C5 yeah by the way this
bishop has now a chance to get to get
out
yeah no this this Knight quickly has to
jump back to C5 but then already Black
Goes Queen E7 probably
also knowing Magnus yeah that and E5 no
no this is running in to see I wasn't
even so sure that Knight D5 is so bad
from every no Magnus goes Magnus is
human
a super human butt but still a human
C5 I mean the screen F5 is is just so
difficult to spot uh and fine claiming
in his famous book that it's winning for
white but uh but as far as I know
computers disagree with uh with this one
yeah yeah okay computers disagree with
so many things but look at this Arjun
goes for ef6 I'm not a fan of this ef6
because I know Magnus is a brilliant
martial player and whenever I see this
light Square Bishop I mean Marshall
comes to mind FG look fd8
it's it just absolutely no go but with
computers your way of thinking changes
dramatically so you have many pluses but
also somewhere it it should bring some
some negativity no I guess I guess so
yeah no I mean in many ways we should
not forget right that uh
uh this guys are just still so young
they still there is still so much
experience which they do not have
what is this I mean this is what we were
afraid of Bishop dominates the Knight
there is a past sea Pawn
yeah don't don't tell me that Arjun will
lose this
could easily happen right it would
easily happen yeah
unbelievable
C1
I would go look CC1 and I think
ah you would go ah like this yeah
and if C2 then I go King H2 G3 and yeah
yeah of course you want to keep this
option you want to keep this option yeah
this is this is correct yeah
I mean G4 was of course a nice move
you have to create this Luft
yeah Anish is on the right track each
dollar line rugby two look CC1 C2 and
then Knight H5 on the board
what to think of this okay Rook B8 he
actually wants to go Rook B1 and Bishop
D1 yeah
yeah that that would be deadly
how do you save this
if Bishop D1 comes
as you highlighted
um I don't see yet
it looks over
now maybe you just kind of play Rook C2
Bishop C2 you move your rook and you
fight no no
I mean okay
no I'm not a believer in this yeah
Bishop D1 on the board
and look at Magnus he's also looking at
like what is your plan my friend yeah I
don't know yeah I don't think he has a
plan yeah yeah no he doesn't maybe there
is no plan
wow Magnus then also seals the match
and from yeah okay but this is Bishop G6
it's Bishop G6 and King G7 yeah that's
that's it that's the designs yeah
yeah
Magnus
takes the match
and uh Magnus takes the match and then
Liam takes the match